after cutting her arm with the broken
glass she fell into a fitful exhausted
exhausted sleep on the railway station
platform early in the morning when the
station toilets were opened
she got painfully to her feet and made
her way over to them when she saw her
reflection in the mirror she started to
cry
her face was dirty and tear stained her
shirt was ripped and covered in blood
she looked as if she'd been on the
streets for three months not three days
she washed herself as best she could her
arms and stomach were hurting badly she
tried to clean the wounds but any
pressure she applied just started the
bleeding again
she needed stitches but there was no way
she would go to a hospital they'd have
sent her back home again back to him she
tightened her jacket
well fastened her jacket tightly to
cover the blood she looked back at
herself in the mirror
she looked through her better than
before but was past caring there was
only one thing she could think of doing
she came out of the station and into a
phone box nearby
Samaritans can I help you
hello Samaritans can I help
what's happened you suck head up soon
one let's start with your name I'm Pam
what can I call you
where we're speaking are you saying it's
in London yeah Oh 14 and what's
happening to make you so upset I just
want to die every day at work I wish I
was dead if she doesn't kill me then I
think I want to do it myself glad you
called let's start at the beginning
Pam continued to gently ask the girl
about herself she didn't say much there
were lots of silences but she knew she
was there and having Pam on the end of
the phone felt so comforting the 14 year
old that made that call was me that was
me in the phone box I was running away
from home sleeping rough I'm asleep on
the streets in London I was being
sexually abused by my father and his
friends I was self harming every day I
was suicidal the first time I called
Samaritans I was 12 and absolutely
desperate there was a few months after
my mother had deserted me walked out and
left me in the family home and the abuse
I was suffering at the hands of my
father and his friends had left me a
total wreck I was running away I was
missing school I was arriving drunk I
was without hope and wanted to die and
that's where Samaritans came in
Samaritans is what's been around since
1953 it's a 24/7 confidential helpline
in the UK for anyone who might be
feeling desperate or suicidal which I
certainly was volunteers answer the
phone around the clock every day of the
year and calls are confidential during
my teenage years when I was most
desperate Samaritans became my lifeline
they promised me total confidentiality
and that allowed me to trust them
disturbing as they no doubt found my
story they never showed it they're
always there for me listen without
judgment
most they gently encouraged me to get
help I never felt out of control with
them an interesting parallel as I felt
so out of control in every other aspect
of my life
in fact my self-harm was probably the
only area where I felt I had any control
a few years later I managed to get some
control in my life and I had appropriate
support around me to allow me to live
with what had happened I'd become a
survivor of abuse rather than a victim
and at 21 I contacted Samaritans again
this time because I wanted to become a
volunteer wants you to pay something
back to the organization that had really
saved my life I knew that the simple act
of listening in an empathetic way could
have a profound effect I knew that
somebody listening to me without
judgment would make the biggest
difference
so I caught up with my education managed
to find well found someone I could
persuade to give me a job and I enjoyed
my volunteering at Samaritans and when I
say enjoy it's a odd word to use because
no one would want to think of anyone
being an absolute distress or pain but I
knew that that profound impact of that
listening ear and someone being
alongside me at that desperate time had
the biggest impact and I felt a great
sense of fulfillment that I was able to
help people as a Samaritan in my years
volunteering at Samaritans uhm I was
asked to perform many roles by best I
guess the peak came in 2008 when I was
asked to chair the organisation for
three years so I'd actually gone from
that vulnerable caller in the phone box
desperate for help to be in the national
lead for the organisation and
responsible for twenty-two thousand
volunteers I actually stood joke joke at
the time and say if he really screwed up
as a call he might end up running the
place which I did but I guess in a world
which is dominated by profession
professionalizing everything we do I
really understood that that simple act
of listening could have such a
life-changing effect I guess it's a
simple concept that can be applied
across all areas of life
so in the 1980s when I called Samaritan
child abuse was a subject no one wanted
to talk about victims were often blamed
victims are often judged and it was a it
was a topic of shame and no one really
wanted to talk about it today judgment
and shame surround a different issue
there's a different stigma that's out
there and the stigma that that's there
today is to talk about loneliness
loneliness and isolation have profound
health impacts being lonely can have a
significant impact on your own
well-being the recent systematic review
of research actually said that it
increased the mortality rates or
premature death rates by up to 30
percent it can lead to high blood
pressure high levels of depression and
actually align to mortality rates that
might be more associated with alcohol
abuse or smoking cigarettes loneliness
is actually more harmful than smoking 15
cigarettes a day not in your life in
your day it's also associated with
higher levels of dementia so a recent
study also found that lonely people are
twice at risk twice or at risk of
Alzheimer's disease of course there's
many people that are lonely though that
many people that live alone who are not
lonely but being a caregiver for a
partner that maybe have has dementia can
be a very lonely place and a recent
landmark study gave us a very good clear
definition of what loneliness is and it
said it's a subjective unwelcome feeling
of a lack or loss of companionship and
it happens when there's a mismatch
between the quality and the quantity of
relationships that we have and those
that we want now in my life the best
help I've ever received
has been from those personal connections
and being listened to in an empathetic
way professionals and I'm conscious I'm
speaking to her in professionals have a
very important place but for me a
volunteer giving up their time and
listening to me without judgment in a
confidential way had such a huge
life-changing effect for me and that was
something that really stayed with me so
she will are gathered in my teenage
years I was off the rails I was going
every day wondering if ID
lift the next day but that profound
impact that the volunteer listening to
me
stayed with me when I finally got to a
point in my life where I felt I could
live with what had happened I wanted to
pay something back and in my experience
people who have been helped in a
transforming way always wants to pay
something back so I started paying back
by my 25 years volunteering with
Samaritans
and then in 2013 picking up on that
whole issue in the new stigma of
loneliness I launched a new national
helpline in the UK for older people
called the Silver Line which is there to
support lonely and isolated older people
in our short history we've taken
one-and-a-half million calls and I know
we're having a big impact based on the
feedback we get every day some people
might be calling up for a friendly chat
maybe some information about local
services some might be calling because
they're suicidal some might be calling
up because they're reporting abuse and
some quite simply as I was may have
simply just given up on life I guess
it's a really simple idea setting up a
helpline and I look back to those early
days when I had the lofty title I still
have of chief exec but in the early days
I was chief exec of myself which I have
to say I had the best meetings ever in
my career as chief exec of myself but
things have moved on and now in 2017 we
have over 200 staff listening to older
people every day of the year 24/7 we
also have over 3,000 volunteers making
weekly friendship calls from their own
home we also for people that like the
written word offer silver letters and we
write pen pal letters to older people
who still enjoy receiving a letter and
we also have you introduced something
called silver circles you notice I'm
owning the word silver here to put put
silver in front of it and it's ours
silver circles which a group conference
calls where people actually talk about
shared interests and my favourite group
is the music group where people every
week play musical instruments down the
phone to each other not always the same
tune at the same time that
but they do have fun and fun is an
interesting word because I've talked
very much about desperation and
loneliness and isolation but if you came
to our help plan in the UK you would
also hear laughter because at the Silver
Line we do want to cherish the live the
wonderful lives of all the people and
all the experiences that they bring so
here's an example just a snippet of one
of our calls good morning you're through
to the Silver Line my name is Alan how
can I help how are you this morning
thank you I'm pleased to hear it
what a wonderful thing the telephone is
you know it's a remarkable invention
isn't it I remember when I was a little
girl don't kill years ago if you wanted
to make a phone call to somebody you had
to go to a shop and use the telephone of
the shop and pay the shop for using the
telephone and have your phone call see
me didn't make phone calls just whenever
you fancy oh no excuse me about that you
had to well you know couldn't find your
phone close to the absolutely essential
and now yet I am sitting in my own home
in my dressing-gown still and that's not
untypical of a call we might receive a
helpline that's someone who really sees
us as part of the family so silver line
I guess are now helping older people in
the same way that Samaritans help me and
they're there 24/7 they're listening
confidentially and quite often not
giving any advice and I guess what I'd
say to you is how often do we really
ever listen without giving advice it's
actually quite hard and quite often on
the phone calls an older person will
ring up and say could you give me some
advice please and 20 minutes later they
say thank you for your advice and we
realize we haven't given any we've
listened and listened and we haven't
interrupted but to that person maybe we
have given advice we recently conducted
a survey at the silver line to 3,000
older people to ask them what they
thought of the service and one person
quite simply came back and said for the
first time you know first time in her
life she had what we would call in the
sport cricket
or wicketkeeper and what you would call
in baseball a catcher I've been here 48
hours and I'm talking American they were
not recognizing it when I get home but
for the first time in her life she had
that catcher which is really really
important and now it's come full circle
because actually people that are calling
silver line and needing a catcher are
now becoming catches themselves by
putting something back and becoming
volunteers and becoming part of our
family so m-my talk really where I
started talking about my own personal
experience because when I talk about my
life I often say that I've been lucky
and people generally ask me why
and it's because at every stage of my
life I have been lucky enough to have
someone alongside me at the right time
who maybe is believed in me which in
turn has helped me just believe a little
bit more in myself which has been so
important and everyone needs a catcher
at some point in their lives this is my
catcher so that's Pam and she answered
the call to me when I was at 14 year old
in the phone box over 30 years ago so
never ever underestimate the power of a
simple human connection because it can
be and so often is the power to save a
life thank you
[Applause]